il faut savoir que toute la semaine
monsieur pons ça on n'a jamais en
réalité donné de réponse à la famille
donc nous en tant qu avocat des parties
civiles
nous avons recherché quelles a pu être
le mobile le plus probable pour lequel
monsieur concerne ceux en décembre 2014
avait enlevé van tien emilie lui avait
fait subir les pires sévices et nous
avons retenu dans les éléments du
dossier
cette journée du 29 novembre 2014 ou là
pour la première fois on est quatre
monsieur pons à de cette famille et à
travers ce nom il va mûrir cette haine
cette frustration qu'il va vouloir faire
passer si madame france est périmé alors
il ya trois éléments que vous faites
ressortir clairement dans votre
plaidoirie
c'est d'abord cette préméditation
ensuite ce violent qui a lieu chez
monsieur pense à et la troisième le
troisième élément c'est donc qu'elle
était encore vivante au moment des faits
au moment où la balance est ce la trace
ah oui nous estimons pour notre part
sans aucun doute que cette dame qui est
dénudé du bas avec quelqu'un qui a déjà
des antécédents en matière sexuelle
comme cela a été démontré toute cette
semaine à la barre que cette malheureuse
a dû être et a été certainement violet
au domicile de cet individu et que c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous le pensons
nous laventie qu'il a voulu justement
effacer toute trace de ce crime en la
poussant toujours vivante à l'allemand
là où il l'a jeté et ça nous l'avons
démontré mercredi où elle l'a montré
dans sa plaidoirie maître mulhousien le
renard le grand également est loin au
départ j'ai effectivement instauré
l'idée selon laquelle nous pensons que
cette femme a été violée puis jetée
vivante à l'allemand